[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: Hello.
Good morning.
Thank you guys so
much for coming.
9:00 AM start-- a
bit after 9:00 AM.
And I see some faces
repeat from yesterday.
So thank you so much
for coming back.
We hope you enjoyed
the experience
that you guys came
and made happen.
We've got an amazing lineup of
speakers again for you today,
but we're going to kick off
with a really short video which
really explains the culture
and the ethos with which we're
running Solve for X.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The actual moonshot is
wonderful, inspirational,
poetic, beautiful, involved
great technical challenges,
genuine heroism.
It brought the world together.
But think about the
Polynesian Islander
in the dugout canoe
deciding one day
they were going to go that way.
No one had ever been
that way before.
No one eve knew if there was
anything that way before.
It was amazing, and
it changed the world.
-People can set their minds to
magical, seemingly impossible
ideas and then through
science and technology
bring them to reality.
And that then sets
other people on fire
that other things
that look impossible
might be accomplishable.
-Many years ago the great
British Explorer George
Mallory, who was to die on Mt.
Everest, was asked, why
did he want to find it.
He said, because it is there.
Everyone else in the world
is working on that next 10%.
If you can be the one that
delivers that 10 times
improvement, you have a chance
to really change things.
-If you want cars to run at
50 miles per gallon, fine,
you can retool your
car a little bit.
But if I tell you it has
to run on a gallon of gas
for 500 miles, you
have to start over.
-You need a lot of
courage in this work,
and you need a lot
of persistence.
Even if you don't really
100% believe it's possible--
like, you might think,
this might be possible.
Have the courage to try.
That's how the greatest
things have happened.
-You don't spend your
time being bothered
that you can't teleport from
here to Japan because there's
a part of you that
thinks it's impossible.
Moonshot thinking is choosing
to be bothered by that.
-We choose to go to
the moon in this decade
and do the other things,
not because they are easy,
but because they are hard.
-Humanity's progress
has been a series
of amazing audacious things
from the very small and personal
up to the great big
and grand, and we
are a species of moonshots.
And to me, that's, like,
the really amazing, poetic,
and inspirational thing.
-When you find your
passion, you're unstoppable.
You can make amazing
things happen.
It's been true through
all of history.
-When Kennedy said that we
would put a man on the moon,
it's about the
fact that he said,
we don't know how
to do this yet,
and we're going to do it anyway.
And that sends shills
up everybody's spine.
Because if that happens,
what couldn't we do?
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: Yay.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
Thanks for coming.
Solve for X is really about a
community of amazing moonshot
pioneers and all of
us who help them.
And sometimes we
think about people--
you know, the
incredible things that
have happened that get
into the history books,
when the people were in the
middle of starting that stuff
and trying to do that stuff, a
lot of people didn't help them
or didn't believe in them or
sort of questioned their ideas.
So Solve for X is a place
where we want to hear and give
a stage to people who have
incredible proposals that
could make a major impact
on our world in some way
and then help them.
And so it's a really
interactive session,
and we're going
to go through it.
So first off, there's this
idea of tech moonshots.
And we think of
them as three parts,
and we ask our speakers to
kind of cover all three.
The first one is,
what's the huge problem
that you're trying to solve?
Or the big opportunity?
And give us some
details about that.
The second part is, what's the
breakthrough technology that
might sound to us
like science fiction,
but you could show us
a little bit about it
and explain how you're
going to apply that-- how
we're going to use
that in this new way.
And what's the radical solution?
Meaning, what kind of
product or service or method
could you use to
actually scale this?
So just as an example, of some
of our colleagues at Google X
work on the self-driving car.
And that's one where, if
you were pitching this,
you would say, OK,
literally billions of people
are wasting hours in
traffic in their lives.
And we have huge safety
concerns, and even more
now with texting and driving
and the security of driving.
And the third is
even fuel efficiency.
And so kind of a
problem worth solving.
The breakthrough technology
is today the level of mapping
and real-time sensors
and robotics, et cetera,
are kind of on the edge where
could a car actually drive
itself in the current system?
Not special rails
not-- so that's
sort of the radical solution.
Can we get it on there?
And many of their early
contests and stuff
showed that was possible.
That was the demo.
And so now that team's trying
to do it as well as others.
So that's sort of how
you would pitch that.
So we've got three
incredible teams
that are going to talk
about their ideas.
And so we're going
to go through that.
Do you want to
talk about method?
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Absolutely.
So what you'll hear is a series
of three 10-minute proposals.
The first proposal
has a fantastic demo
that we're really
excited about so that
will go a little bit longer.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: fly around.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: And
then we're going to do--
and the most important
part of Solve for X--
is the interactive
brainstorming sessions
that we do following
these talks.
So it's a chance for all of
you to really think about
if you were to join this
team, if you were to suddenly
be a part of pushing this
forward, thinking 2/3 yes--
it's a concept we borrowed
from improv-- what ideas, what
resources, what connections
might you be able to think
of that can help accelerate
the progress on this project?
And then spend a 1/3 of the
time thinking about, yes,
but-- what are the
questions that you still
have in your mind?
What are some of the
critiques that maybe we
haven't discussed or talked
about in enough detail.
And then we're going to
get each of the teams
to quickly come up after
this 25-minute session
of brainstorming and report
out to the moonshot pioneers
and everyone else in the
room some of the findings
that you guys have
discussed in these groups.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
you might think,
I'm not going to
know about that.
But you'll find
that at your table
there's going to be some people
who know a lot and people who
know nothing about
what was just said,
and both people will
have fabulous ideas
for these pioneers.
And it really helps them.
So without further
ado we'll get started.
Our next speaker has
come a very long way.
Like, 30 something hours flying,
yesterday landing from Ethiopia
with lots of struggling
with the US State Department
to get his visa.
So Michael, come on up.
One of the biggest
challenges we have
is that all the kids on
the edge, 50 million kids,
have no access to any kind
of learning because there's
no schools, there's
now teachers,
and people around
them didn't get access
to learning so they have
no literacy and numeracy.
And we kind of wait
for the governments
to solve this problem and
build schools and do that,
and it's just too slow.
There's also about
500 million kids
who have kind of bad school
where their teachers just
don't show up or
check each other in
or the teachers were
never trained properly.
And so there's
several people who've
been working for years
on things like the OLPC
$100 laptop and those projects.
And some of those
most amazing people
who have been working on
them have been in the field
and have the best information
about what's working
and what's not working.
And so Michael is
part of the teams that
have worked on the $100 laptop
projects now into the reading
project, and he's going
to talk a little bit
about those learnings and
some of their insights
and what they
think we should get
done with hyperlocal solutions.
I think, as you guys start,
you're going to play a video?
MICHAEL GIRMA: Morning, guys.
My name is Michael Girma.
I've been working on education
for the last eight years,
and my two and a half years of
experience in the last years
is really quite impressive.
When I started work on this
globe literacy reading research
program, original idea
by Nicholas Negroponte
and with MIT Media Lab.
So let me take you
to a small video.
And we'll go through
my presentation.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
you
MICHAEL GIRMA: Yeah.
So he's also one of
my colleagues working
on the global literacy program.
So to start my
presentation, there
are around 250 million
kids all over the world
who don't have access to school.
And around 793 million adults
who cannot read and write,
and 60% of them are women.
So let's see why the
kids don't go to school
or can't go to school.
So there are quite
a few reasons why
they are not going to school.
So the first reason is
the average distance
from their school
to their village
is at least two
and a half hours.
So for a three or four-year-old
kid to go to school
and come back to a really rough
situation is almost impossible.
The other thing
is that people who
are living in these
rural areas are
have a lot of
socio-economic problems
so they don't send
their kids to school,
but instead they want the kids
to help them in housework,
in collecting wood for
cooking and for fire,
and fetching water from
the rivers, which is always
a long distance to
go and come back,
and also the boys are usually
going with the cattle.
So not only those reasons,
but also the urban settlement
and the geographical
structure makes
it's really hard to provide
a health station, a school,
and other necessarily
things for the community.
And apart from that, one
of the major problems
is also the environmental
and health issues.
So with all these ideas in
mind, in February, 2012,
for the first time we
tried to deploy or drop off
the tablets in those
two villages, Wenchi and
[? Welcheti. ?]
So our first
experience was having
the idea of kids who
don't to have access
to school can read and
write by using technology,
without any instruction,
and without any teacher.
So there are a bunch
of apps on the tablet
and we just gave them
out and started to watch.
Within four minutes, a kid
by the name of [INAUDIBLE]
turned on the tablet
for the first time.
And he was really
quite impressed,
and he showed the other
kids how he did it,
and it took less time
than the first time.
So the kids always
shared their experiences.
After a week, we just went back
and saw how they were doing,
and we were fascinated by
the performance of the kids.
It is really hard to believe
that those kids in a week--
or in the first four
weeks-- did this kind
of amazing performance.
So we were quite impressed and
started to do the research.
And one of the
interesting things
is that we selected the
ages between four to ten
because we wanted to
focus on that age group.
But those kids who
were below that age
and also above the
age of ten, they
were influenced by the others.
So they started to sing a song,
like ABC, in the community
and playing games which
were on the tablet
and doing some really
fancy stuff together
with the other kids.
So they are supporting
their families
so the families are not
complaining about the kids
because this is a new thing
and they are more comfortable.
So after five months,
this kid, [INAUDIBLE],
who claimed himself a lion,
he unlocked the tablet
for the first time, and
we really quite impressed
because we blocked
the camera apps
because we don't want to
affect the community privacy
and the data is going to be
too big if kids take a picture.
So we blocked the camera apps.
But he found out
how to unlock it.
So this is [INAUDIBLE].
The interesting part is that
maybe he just did it simply
randomly.
But that's not true, because
after a week all of the 41 kids
knew how to unlock it.
So this is how it spreads.
It's quite amazing.
When you give them something
which is relevant for them,
it spreads quite quickly.
And the other interesting part
is they charge it once in a day
so they just use it
wherever they go.
But they saved the battery
and in the evening,
they tried to study
with their parents.
And also used the tablet's
power as a source of light
in their house because they
don't have electricity.
So they work in the
evening with their parents.
So the kids' confidence.
We just saw them on the first
day that we give it to them.
They are really quite shy.
But after some time, they
are really confident.
Especially when you're
asking them some questions,
they are confidential to answer.
Because they are already solving
any problems by themselves
rather than looking to others.
So they are really confident.
So after a year with one of
the scientists from Tufts
University, we tried to
measure the kids to see
if they are really reading,
writing, and if they learned.
The results are
quite impressive.
At that time, they
are at the level
of a kindergarten student.
They can read some words,
they can write some words,
and it's promising
that they're going
to do something in the future.
These were some
of the equations.
Most of the applications
are not designed
in the context of
the local community.
Rather, we just brought it
straight from the shelf.
So octopus, donkey,
and ice cream.
So they don't know
octopus and ice cream
so they have got some visual
problems when they see this.
But when they see donkey,
they are really quite fast
and understand it well.
So for this problem we're
trying to develop some apps
based on local context.
So the other issue is
some of the parents--
a few of the parents-- were
not happy with the kids.
They don't believe
that they are studying
because it's a new thing.
So this is also
a little problem.
So looking at all these
experiences and the kids'
efforts to study,
we just say, like,
OK, this is the time
to do something.
We can do something.
So with my friend
Marcos we tried
to sit down and think
about what to do.
And we just found out
this global literacy hub,
it's a network or hub,
which works on literacy.
So we tried to connect
all African hubs
to work on literacy, especially
to design and develop
local content.
So local problems
with local solutions.
So our approach is a
bottom-up approach.
Providing local solutions
for local problems.
So the kids have
skills so that they
are the ones who are going
to solve their own problems
after five years, ten years.
They don't expect someone
to solve their own problems.
So we're planning to design
not only a tablet, but also
some hardware which can
be helpful for the kids
in order to achieve
reading and writing skills.
Maybe one last thing, ethics,
skills, and critical thinking
are the basic things
which we are focused on.
So we're trying to
teach them those things
and see them changing the world.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
So a quick question before
Scott comes up, Michael,
so we see this as such amazing
moonshot to take all the stuff.
It's almost like
the future's here,
it's not evenly distributed.
And so these are
Android tablets.
We have them here, now
the kids have them.
But what we really
loved was your insight
to have local people
versus octopuses--
they can learn about
octopuses later--
but local people who have much
for context working with them
and having people
like themselves.
Is there any question,
as people brainstorm,
that you would love them to
help you with in addition
to anything-- any imaginative
things-- they think of
or critical things they
think to be worried about it?
MICHAEL GIRMA: Well, I really
don't have much to say,
but we have the solution.
Our solution is in our hands.
But thinking in the
right way is the only way
to solve those problems.
So especially local
solutions in a local context.
As I told you in the
beginning of my presentation,
there are economic
problems, there
are environmental problems,
there are health problems
so if they are focused on
those kinds of social issues,
they are the ones who
are going to solve
those issues in the future.
So that's our main
target and focus.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: OK, great.
All right.
So next up.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
So I actually heard octopus
in Ethiopian culture
was supposed to represent demons
or witches so maybe that's
not the best thing
to be showing kids.
Next up we have
Scott Klemer who is
from the University of
California San Diego.
And to continue the
theme with education,
Scott is going to be
talking to us about how
moocs and online education can
really change the way that we
think about how we
structure our curriculum
and structure our learning.
SCOTT KLEMER: Good morning.
It's great to be here.
I had an amazing middle school
math teacher, Mr. Frasier,
and he told us that
learning is teaching
and that the first person
that you teach is yourself
and the second person that
you teach is your friend.
And one goal of
this Google X series
is to foster order of
magnitude, even multiple order
of magnitude, changes.
And so I wanted to
enlist your help
today in thinking
with me about how
we can scale Mr.
Frasier's insight.
And in particular,
I'd like to focus
on doing this to
learn creative skills.
An increasing number of
jobs are knowledge sector
creatively intensive jobs.
And this is also a lot
of what we do outside
of work and in
our lives as well.
And there's a huge amount of
enthusiasm for this right now.
It was amazing this morning
to see the line snaked
around the block to
be able to get in.
I'm not I used to that a
conferences that I go to.
And there's a whole lot of
people who don't have access
to the creative and technical
content that's available today.
And we want lots of people
to have these skills.
Lots of people
want these skills.
How can we address
this need at scale?
Before becoming a cognitive
and computer scientist,
I was originally
trained as a designer.
And here you see a
couple of design studios.
The traditional design
fields rely strongly
on this studio
model of education.
It was founded in 1819 when the
l'Ecole des Beaux-Arts in Paris
got going.
And it's flourished
and really grown
over the last two
centuries I think because
of the benefits
of peer learning.
The ability to see what
your friends are working on,
to be energized by a critique.
But this doesn't scale.
This is the most high-touch
teaching approach
you can imagine.
So how would we do
something at scale online?
I think that, in
a lot of ways, we
can turn this problem
into a solution.
My colleague, Jim
Holland, famously
observed that the most exciting
opportunities for online media
are when you get to go
beyond being there as opposed
to just making a poor
facsimile of the real world.
Do something that's
different, that
leverages the power
of computation.
So what we've been doing
in my research group
is we've been
exploring ways that we
can use the scale of
massive online classes
to be able to foster new
kinds of peer interactions.
And I'm going to share, briefly,
a couple examples of this
with you today.
A couple of years ago, in
collaboration with Coursera,
we started to put my
design class online.
And we were thinking
about, well,
how would we have the
project work be something
that was available
for all the students?
And my colleague,
Ed Hutchins, gave me
the courage to use
peer assessment
and see if we could scale that
up to a planet scale class.
He'd been using it for a
couple hundred students
really remarkably.
And so Ed gave us the
courage to build this out.
And it worked remarkably well.
The way that it works is that
we have students first practice
assessing their peers.
This is a new technique
and a new skill for them.
By the way, it's also
a really useful skill
to have in addition to
having the outcome of being
able to grade assignments.
So after we train you up
on assessing your peers,
you'll go out and get five
randomly assigned assignments,
one of which we know
the score for so
that we can check
a ground truth.
And at the end of
it all, we have
you self-assess your
own work as well,
which it's valuable to learn
to become your own critic.
And what we found is that
this works really well.
More than 90% of the students
in a pass-fail class,
like a lot of these
online classes,
get the certificate
that they deserve.
Peers are a little
bit lenient so there
are a couple of people who
sneak in and get a certificate
even though maybe they
didn't do all of the work.
There are, however,
corner cases.
And one reason that I'm
excited to be here today
is that I think things at scale,
the corner cases scale, too.
And I wanted to think a little
bit about what we can do there.
And this has been used in more
than 100 other online classes.
In general it works really well.
And what we found is that it
doesn't work automatically.
You can find blog posts
where people are really
frustrated by having a wingnut
grade their hard wrought work.
And what we've seen is that
there are some strategies that
are important for being able
to do peer assessment well.
And so we've worked
a lot on being
able to teach the
teachers and being
able to bake these
into software.
One of the things that's
really fun is getting a score
is nice and all, but
it's valuable to be
able to get some more
personalized feedback.
And for many of you out
there who are teachers,
you know that
students always crave
more personalized feedback.
This is true even at
the massive scale.
What we did is we realized that
a lot of the feedback that we
were seeing is in
variations on a theme.
So we packaged up
these fortune cookies
which codify common
bits of feedback
and then students can customize
those to give them to peers.
A worry about these
massive online classes,
you may have tens or even
hundreds of thousands
of students who are
taking these classes
and yet maybe we're
all alone together.
Maybe it's just 100,000
people around the world
staring at a laptop and
having no engagement.
And, again, what makes
design so exciting
is that you have
that opportunity be
in the studio with others.
The community is really
the most important part,
and so what we did is we came
up with this system called
Talk About, which leverages
Google Hangouts to be
able to offer many, many,
many small group discussions
in massive classes.
We first rolled this out in
Scott Plous' Social Psychology
class.
And students described
the experience
of being able to talk with peers
as, wow, it's like a mini UN.
We had an Australian, a
Dubai, and Afghan, a Romanian,
an Indian and my
self, a Pakistani.
And what we see is that not
only do students feel really
energized after participating
in these discussions--
and they're really cool to be
able to sit-in on-- students
who participate in a
randomly controlled trial
in a high-diversity
discussion condition
actually performed better
subsequently in the class
than those that were in a
low-diversity condition.
So I think, especially for
domains like social psychology,
seeing diverse perspectives can
be a really powerful learning
motivator.
One reason that people
are often surprised when
I talk about being able
to scale peer learning
is that there's an
intrinsic paradox.
You're asking novices
to do something
that definitionally
only experts can do.
The reason that you're the
teacher and not the student
is that you have the
ability to do the grading
and create the content.
And when we flip this and have
more peer-focused efforts,
I think that the
key to making it
work is creating micro-experts.
And this is similar
in spirit to the work
that, for example, the
Folding@home protein folding
folks have done where
you can train people up
in a narrow domain and build
useful skills as long as you
design that experience
very carefully.
And so recently
we've been exploring
moving from a score-based
approach, which actually
requires a fair
amount of expertise,
to a more attribute or
label-based approach.
So what are the attributes
of this assignment
that you see here?
And that works a lot better.
And it discourages
laziness as well,
which is important in reducing
those outlier wingnuts.
Another thing that we can do
is, although machine learning
is not at the point--
yet, at least-- where
we can automatically grade
creative assignments,
it can help a lot.
And so we've
explored-- because we
have this large corpus
of training data,
we worked with Richard
[INAUDIBLE] and colleagues
to be able to have an NLP-based
system be one of the peer
graders or something
that helps do triage
on student submissions.
And we found that by adding the
structure combining students
doing the label-based
grading and then verify it,
we can add a machine
in to be able to reduce
the overall workload
and at the same time
give people higher
quality feedback.
So the moonshot that I'm
sharing with you today
is I think that we can use
strategies like this-- so far
we've just scratched
the surface--
to be able to in situ
build practical theory
with large-scale real
world experiments.
And part of what enables this
to be both possible and powerful
is that with online
education one thing
that I think hasn't
been noticed enough
is that you're baking a lot
of pedagogy into software.
And this makes it much
easier to transform
learning to other classes.
If we come up with something
really good in one class,
by virtue of being in
software, it automatically
moves to the other one.
And when I talk
about theory here,
I'm really inspired by the
worker of Kurt Lewin who
was a social psychologist
of the last century who
said that "the best way
to understand something
is to try and change it."
And so to generalize
this strategy,
to x-ify this strategy, what
we want to be able to do
is now that we have,
with the power of lots
of connected devices,
the ability to run
actual real controlled
experiments, the kind of thing
that we used to only be
able to do in the lab.
We can do that in
the real world now.
We can do those
experiments toward goals
that people really care about.
And we can use that
to bubble up theory--
and this is the step that I
think industry doesn't always
need to do immediately,
so it often
gets left on the
cutting room floor.
We can bubble that up
in a way that's reusable
that can help other
people as well.
So what we can offer
here and this is we
have some open-source
platforms that this URL here
that have analytics and course
materials and constructor
resources as well.
And your mission, if
you choose to accept it,
is to think with me today
about how we might scale more
personalized
mastery-oriented learning
experiences to this
new global community.
I want to thank
the ton of people
who did all of this work.
You can read more about it on
my website or Twitter feed.
And I hope that some of you
will join the many students who
are going to take the next
around of the HCI class
starting on June 30.
Thank you very much.